Migration Riesenthema auch wieder für
die bundesinnenministerin die ja in den
nächsten Wochen im Wahlkampf in Hessen
unterwegs ist das heißt irgendjemand
muss das Thema dann übernehmen der
Bundespräsident steinmeier sagte gestern
auf seiner Italienreise Deutschland ist
an der Belastungsgrenze
hat er recht wir sprechen ja mit vielen
oberbürgermeisterinnen
Oberbürgermeisterin Landräten in meinem
eigenen Wahlkreis durchaus alles voll
bei ihnen durchaus genau und und sind da
im natürlich im ständigen Austausch die
die die Bundesregierung die andere
Regierung hat
wesentliche Dinge vorangebracht mit der
Beschleunigung der Asylverfahren mit der
Erhöhung von von Beschleunigung von
Rückführungen auch
aber eben Beschleunigung von
Rückführungen
angestiegen von der kleinen von von
einem kleinen niedriger das ist
vollständig richtig das ist ja Aufgabe
der der Bundesländer Einführungen durch
viele führen die das sind sehr sehr
kleine Zahlen aber sie sind gestiegen
und es ist ja es ist ja ich kenne die
Zahl aber die müssen wir jetzt hier
nicht ausführen wir müssen wir müssen
drauf blicken ob es vorwärts geht ob es
besser werden
darum kann es nicht gehen dass wir jetzt
hier diskutieren wie viel Rückführungen
in welchem Bundesland durchgeführt
worden sind mit welchem Erfolg von
welcher auseinander
relevant gestiegen um 27% soweit ich
weiß aber das ist doch das ist doch
nicht der Punkt sondern der Punkt ist
dass wir viel beigebracht viel
beigetragen haben dazu das ist besser
wird und dennoch sind natürlich die
Zahlen die insgesamt
gestiegen und deswegen sind die Kommunen
weiterhin unter entsprechenden Druck wir
haben vor allem auch im letzten Jahr
eine Million ein bisschen über eine
Million geflüchtete Ukraine aufgenommen
und es ist ja das wird ja in den in den
in den ähm weiteren Zahlen aus anderen
Ländern gar nicht mit eingerechnet das
ist eine riesen Leistung unserer
Kommunen und dass da die Schulen dass da
die Kitas dass die Wohnungen dass die
Unterkünfte überall überlastet sind ist
nachvollziehbar wir haben diese große
Aufgabe gemeinsam zu leisten und
deswegen haben wir jetzt auch uns der
Aufgabe angenommen wie gesagt
Asylverfahren zu beschleunigen damit
eben die Anerkennungen schneller
stattfinden dann die Integration auch
besser stattfinden kann aber eben auch
die Ablehnung und damit dann auch die
Rückführung und ich erinnere jetzt an
den
vorgängerinnenminister Seehofer der auch
schon
Rückführungsabkommen mit vielen Ländern
schließen wollte in der ganzen Welt dazu
unterwegs war aber leider ohne jeden
Erfolg also dass die Leute kommen ist
sicherlich ihre Schuld aber die Frage
damit wir auftragt und jetzt geht es
auch voran
dass die Leute kommen ist nicht ihre
Schuld aber die Frage wie wird damit
umgehen die können sie gestalten absolut
so und das tun wir sie sagen wir führen
signifikant mehr Leute zurück sie sagen
sind 27%
sie kennen die Zahlen nicht es ist eine
sehr kleine Zahl wie wir beide wissen
dann ist 27% nichts was angesichts der
der vielen Menschen die kommen ernsthaft
relevant ist deswegen sind die
Migrationen deswegen sind die
migrationsabkommen so wichtig weil ja in
vielen Fällen die Rückführungen deswegen
nicht gelingen weil die Herkunft
ich kann Ihnen die Zahl jetzt liefern
7.861 Rückführungen im ersten Halbjahr
in der vergangenen Woche nur in einer
Woche sind
10.000 Menschen bewusst ist mir durchaus
bewusster die migrationsabkommen sind
ganz entscheidend weil wir eben nur da
nicht funktioniert ja die werden auch
nicht funktionieren weil es funktioniert
nicht funktioniert
Seehofer hat ja wie gesagt
Rückführungsabkommen versucht zu
verhandeln aber ohne jedes wir reden
jetzt über heute der einzige
Einzelhandel weil da nichts zu bieten
hat einigermaßen funktioniert hat war
der sogenannte die türkei-deal der ist
aber speziell weil natürlich die Türkei
durch NATO-Mitgliedschaft und immer noch
das Bestreben vielleicht eines Tages in
die EU aufgenommen werden damit der
Unterschied ist die Länder mit denen
jetzt verhandelt ich glaube nicht mehr
daran dass über diese migrationsabkommen
signifikant etwas erreicht werden
den Unterschied zu erklären Seehofer hat
versucht Rückführungsabkommen zu
schließen das heißt Abkommen mit Ländern
die eben abgelehnte Asylbewerber
zurücknehmen sollen er hatte aber nichts
im Gegenzug zu bieten was ist es beim
Abkommen das kann nicht klappen wir
sagen wir brauchen Zuwanderung wir
wollen legale Zuwanderungswege
ermöglichen für Menschen die die
Qualifikation mitbringen die wir
brauchen
unbedingt noch von zwei Personen nein
nein das gehört zusammen das gehört
zusammen das soll in den
migrationsabkommen genau so verhandelt
werden
wir haben legale Zuwanderungswege zu
beten für Menschen die Qualifikation
mitbringen die wir brauchen oder die
Bereitschaft in der Ausbildung zu gehen
und gleichzeitig nicht haben wir aber
den Deal auch dass eben abgelehnte
Asylbewerber zurückgenommen mit Tunesien
mit Tunesien also wird ein solches
migrationsabkommen ja sogar mit der EU
verhandelt und nicht nur nicht nur mit
Deutschland Herr stammt funktioniert
Herr stammt das ist ja noch nicht
geschlossen dann kann es auch noch nicht
funktionieren nur nur damit man die
Größenordnung klar wird deswegen ist es
eben nicht trivial über welche Zahlen
wir reden ob wir die kennen oder nicht
kennen und ob die wichtig sind oder
nicht ich finde sie sind enorm wichtig
eine einzige Stadt in Tunesien letzten
Mittwoch
120 Boote an einem einzigen Tag die sich
auf den Weg machen metallbote sind
mittlerweile metallbote
wo soll dein Abkommen funktionieren
das Abkommen funktioniert dann wenn wir
wenn wir gleichzeitig auch mit dem mit
dem Geras noch mal stärker die
Außengrenzen Europas sichern wenn wir
wenn wir wenn wir wirklich
aussehen können
das haben wir uns gemeinsam mit der
Europäischen Union vorgenommen dass dort
der Einsatz von Kontext auch verstärkt
werden soll dazu muss von Text dazu muss
man Text aber auch befähigt werden und
dann müssen natürlich mehr Boote
unterwegs
es geht natürlich nicht darum
pushbacks zu machen
Migranten zurückzuschicken aufs offene
Meeren das machen sie egal
eine Pflicht nach internationalen Recht
was macht es geht darum dass dass die
Leute nicht über illegale Aufnahme in in
Länder einreisen sondern dass sie in den
Asylzentren dann ankommen die dort
eingerichtet werden
wir nicht nein machen wir nicht weil die
illegal sind natürlich nicht okay was
machen wir dann wir nehmen in den in die
in die grenzverfahren auf das haben wir
ja vereinbart das muss im auf
europäische Ebene also im Rad wurde es
vereinfacht muss jetzt umgesetzt werden
im Trilog ähm dann werden
dann werden die ankommenden geflüchteten
an der Grenze an der Grenze registriert
und aufgenommen und dann wird
entschieden
nicht wieder in wie in lambidosa noch
wie in Moria aber sondern eben in
befestigten gut eingerichteten
ankunftszentren wo dann wo dann wo dann
relativ schnell entschieden wird gibt es
eine hohe bleibe Wahrscheinlichkeit oder
gibt es eine sehr geringe
Wahrscheinlichkeit ja an dem Grenzen
aber
in welchem Land wo stehen überall da wo
geflüchtete ankommen
ja und das in Lampedusa gibt es ja auch
eine solche Einrichtung sie ist nur
vollkommen überlaufen und zwar deshalb
und zwar deshalb weil dort die Behörden
haben komplett überfordert sind und
deswegen das sind die Bilder dazu
deswegen muss die Europäische Union
genau diese Bilder die Europäische Union
muss jetzt Verantwortung übernehmen für
die für die zum einen die Registrierung
an den Außengrenzen zum zum anderen die
schnelle Entscheidung kann jemand
bleiben ja oder nein und dann auch die
solidarische Verteilung auf die auf die
auf die Mitgliedstaaten okay die haben
wir ja heute auch nicht sie wissen genau
dann auch das von den ankommenden in der
Europäischen Union derzeit über 30% nach
Deutschland kommen okay dann nur eine
Frage nicht funktioniert ja genau
wir lassen die Leute weiterhin
übers Mittelmeer kommen irgendwie und
dann kommen sie in ein besseres wie sie
sagen befestigtes aufnahmelade auf
Lampedusa das bauen wir dann wir müssen
mit den Menschen die einen kommentieren
das ist humane Flüchtlingspolitik dann
wir müssen mit den Menschen die ankommen
human umgehen wir müssen vor allem
entscheiden wir müssen vor allem
entscheiden wer bleiben können wer nicht
bleiben kann und wir werden durch diese
migrationsabkommen eben auch wirklich
machen dass diejenigen die sich jetzt
zwar auf dem auf der Grundlage des
Asylrechts auf den Weg machen zu uns
aber gar keine Asylgründe vorzuweisen
haben dass die andere Wege haben um bei
uns eine wirtschaftliche Person muss die
Regie noch mal bitte vielleicht können
die Kollegen das eben was wir eben
gesehen haben bitte noch einmal ein
Spiel ich habe wirklich noch mal eine
Frage das heißt da machen sich Menschen
auf den Weg da können wir das noch mal
zuspielen dann spielen sich solche
Szenen ab die Leute kommen irgendwie an
120 metallbote teils an einem einzigen
Tag
und wer es irgendwie geschafft hat dahin
zu kommen zu dem sagen wir du
glücklicher du hast es hierher geschafft
wir wissen dass auf dem Weg durch die
Wüste sind Leute verdurstet du hast
Freunde verloren da sind Leute und teils
auch kleine Kinder auf dem Mittelmeer
ertrunken aber gratuliere ihr habt sie
her geschafft und jetzt wunderbar
kümmern wir uns um Euch und das ist
unsere humane Flüchtlingspolitik und
wenn man mal genau hinschaut ist auch
interessant ich sehe hier nur junge
Männer ich verstehe warum weil keine
Frau keine Mutter mit Kindern wirklich
arme Menschen wirklich arme Menschen die
es dann auch noch mal gibt Arme auch im
Sinne von könnte das kräftemäßig gar
nicht unterernährt und so weiter die
können das nicht die kommen da gar nicht
hin das ist doch keine humane
flüchtlingspolizei sondern wir haben
natürlich in den bei den beim Zustrom
der der
Asylbewerber nach Deutschland und in
andere Länder auf der ganzen Welt
einige schlechteren alle Altersklassen
mit dabei das wissen sie auch ja aber
wir müssen wissen nein weitere Schule
müssen weiterhin wir können diese Art
von das ist ein ganz beinharter brutaler
Ausleseprozess da kommt nur durch wenn
der Lage ist kräftemäßig das irgendwie
zu überstehen ich habe dieser Tage von
zwei jungen gambieren eine
Erfahrungsbericht gelesen die sagen
würde ich nie wieder machen ich würde
sogar so weit gehen und sagen wir führen
die Leute auf eine Art und Weise in
Versuchung das zu probieren auf der
Suche nach einem besseren Leben und ich
frage mich ist das ernsthaft humane
Flüchtlingspolitik wenn wir das dann
irgendwie auf Lampedusa oder woanders
logistisch vielleicht hinkriegen dass
die armen Teufel ist irgendwie was
Mittelmeer geschafft haben vorher durch
die Wüste geschafft haben die letzte
Kohle zusammengekratzt haben um
Schlepper zu bezahlen mit tausenden
den geben wir dann auf die Art und Weise
vielleicht eine Chance bringen jetzt
auch zwei Dinge zusammen die ich vorher
mit unter Protest von Herrn Schwenningen
zusammengebracht hat nämlich Menschen
die sich auf dem Weg nach einer
Perspektive ja auf der Suche nach einer
Perspektive auf dem Weg zu uns machen
das sind aber keine Asylbewerber sind
auch keine Kriegsflüchtlinge sondern das
sind eben Menschen die eine Perspektive
suchen ja viele haben aber genau die
haben aber ja im Asylrecht nichts
verloren da sind wir uns einig ja sind
wir uns einig genau und deswegen
brauchen wir mit den Herkunftsländern
migrationsabkommen genau in der Frage
wie kriegen wir hin dass sie sich auf
den Weg das abgelehnt der asylbewerbung
Moment das abgelehnt der Asylbewerber
zurückgenommen werden zurückgeschickt
werden können und das eben junge
Menschen die sich auf den Weg machen um
eine Perspektive bei uns zu suchen wenn
sie tatsächlich auch entweder eine
Qualifikation mitbringen die wir
brauchen oder bereits in sich die
anzueignen dass sie dann eben auf dem
legalen Weg zu uns kommen auf dem
regulären zuwanderungsweg
und dann ohne Schleuser ohne Boote ohne
ohne Lebensgefahr und natürlich auch
Männer Frauen Familien die bei uns eine
Zukunft suchen und nicht nur Deutschland
sondern auch Italien und andere Länder
in Europa in Europa haben ein Problem
mit Fachkräften und haben ein Problem
mit der Demographie
die haben aber kein Problem kein
ernsthaftes Problem mit geflüchteten im
Moment weil die Leute ja erstmal mit der
Logistik na diese Bilder sind ja gewollt
die da entstehen das will man so man
will Druck aufbauen und man schickt die
Leute doch ein Großteil der Leute direkt
nach Deutschland weiter das wissen sie
auch also ich weiß auch dass sie
Bevölkerung in Lampedusa durchaus immer
wieder auch bereit ist dort zu helfen wo
sie sind fix und fertig ja wir wollen
jetzt nicht das Problem von Italien oder
Griechenland oder anderen Staaten
kleinen reden wir lassen die lassen mit
dem Thema an der Grenze sein und
deswegen ist ein solidarisches
europäisches Asylsystem ja auch so
dringend notwendig aber ich will schon
auch deutlich machen dass diese
migrationsabkommen deshalb fliegen
können weil wir ja Zuwanderung brauchen
wir brauchen aber reguläre und wir
brauchen qualifizierte Zuwanderung und
vor allem nicht so eine chaotische nicht
eine die schleuserkriminalität
organisierte schleuserkriminalität
finanziert das kann ja nicht unser Weg
sein genau
strukturiert zu argumentieren also es
ist jetzt acht Jahre später klar dass
wir schaffen das ist in ein es geht
nicht mehr übergegangen dieser Befund
ist glaube ich inzwischen allgemeinen
anerkannt deswegen hat der
Bundespräsident alt Bundespräsident Gauk
ja vor ein paar Tagen auch gesagt dass
eine neue Entschlossenheit bei diesem
Thema her muss er hat es nicht aus
Buchstaben auch keine goldrandlösung
sein aber ich glaube mit Verlaub Frau
eskim ihre ihr Vertrauen in ihre
Hoffnung in diesem migrationsabkommen
wird nicht reichen also erstens geht es
darum Grenzen zu sichern und zu schützen
zu Wasser und zu Land und zu Wasser
bedeutet neben Frontex nur weil es Frau
Meloni gesagt hat ist es nicht falsch
unter Umständen auch Marine so dann
brauche ich also
Asylzentren an dieser Außengrenze ich
mache es präziser vor dieser Außengrenze
also wahrscheinlich schwimmend weil die
Länder in denen gestartet wird wir haben
bisher keine Offenheit gezeigt diese
Zentren
120 Boote an einem Tag losfahren ich ich
kann mir eine schlechte organisierte
tunesische Behörde nicht vorstellen die
das nicht sieht ja aber ja aber das
werden sie nicht verhindern können sie
werden nicht so viel Einfluss nehmen
können
dagegen werden sie wenig machen können
also müssen sie aufgebracht werden und
schwimmend in Asyl oder in schwimmende
Asylzentren gebracht werden und dort
muss sehr schnell entschieden werden ich
weiß es ist eine Herkulesaufgabe wer
darf kommen und wenn nicht um zu
vermeiden dass die dieses Jahr aber die
Beine auf den europäischen Boden gesetzt
werden weil dann das nicht funktioniert
mit dem zu tun sagte dass die
materiellen oder auch finanziellen
Anreize
verringert werden müssen sie dürfen
jedenfalls nicht so groß sein dass der
Sog weiterhin so stark da ist jetzt sage
ich noch was viertes für die die jetzt
es geschafft haben hier mit all den
Strapazen die Herr lands beschrieben hat
da habe ich meine Meinung auch geändert
da würde ich sagen okay alle
Möglichkeiten geben um auch Stichwort
Spurwechsel in Arbeit zu kommen weil es
für dieses Land Europa besser ist wenn
die Leute Arbeit haben und ihren
Tatendrang es sind meistens junge Männer
so ausleben und nicht sich ein Bahnhöfen
oder öffentlichen Parks langweilen so
das sind akutmaßnahmen die man jetzt
machen müsste weil es geht so nicht mehr
weiterverhalten
absolut die letzte die letzte Maßnahme
haben wir bereits ergriffen das heißt
Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht und es muss
eben jetzt aber von der Kultur her auch
umgesetzt werden wir haben ja im in der
großen Koalition schon dieses drei plus
zwei recht gemacht das wäre eine
Ausbildung gemacht auch wenn er nur eine
Duldung hat die Sicherheit hat drei
Jahre plus 2 Jahre
es ist leider kaum umgesetzt worden weil
eben auch eine Kultur in unserem in
unserer in unseren Behörden unserer
Bevölkerung entstanden ist unter anderem
zum Beispiel durch einen Vorgänger
Innenminister der gesagt hat Migration
sei die Mutter aller Probleme die eben
nicht unbedingt jetzt den die
geflüchteten als als Chance auf den
beschäftigungs auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
sieht die ist aber da ja also ich habe
in dem im Wahlkreis eine syrische
Familie der der älteste Sohn macht jetzt
eine Banklehre der ist 2015 hierher
gekommen nee Banklehre machen bei uns
nur die die echt richtig gute Abschlüsse
machen richtig gute Schulabschlüsse also
die Leute haben ja
das ist nicht nur anekdotisch weil wir
wissen dass dann 40% der Erwerbsfähigen
die damals gekommen sind jetzt in
erwerben weil sie gerade Syrien sagen
weißt du nur ganz kurz die Zahl 500.000
Syrer sind im Moment im Bürgergeld davon
sind 320.000 eigentlich arbeitsfähig ja
wir bringen die Leute nicht in den
Arbeitsmarkt ich kann auch was über den
Vater sagen der Vater hat auch Arbeit ja
ich glaube
ja alles aber
gefragt was er in Syrien gemacht hat was
sein Beruf war
er war Richter
wir vergeuden die Leute und ihre Talente
und ihre Fähigkeiten das muss man auch
dazu sagen
zurück zu den zurück zu den schwimmenden
Asylzentren das ist ja rechtlich gar
nicht möglich man kann außerhalb der
Europäischen Union keinen Asylantrag
stellen wie sollen das Gehen den kann
man erst stellen wenn man
doch auch schon genauso über
singlezentren in den startländern
gesprochen
und wer hat das mittlerweile aufgegeben
zum Beispiel Dänemark haben diese Pläne
aufgegeben weil sie offenkundig nicht
durchführbare Politik
gefährden die funktioniert ja nicht das
heißt wir müssen auf dem europäischen
Festland aber eben an der Grenze diese
Verfahren durchführen das ist doch genau
passiert mit der geraseinigung
vereinbart ist dass sind die Zentren
eingerichtet werden in Moria ist es auch
schon gebaut worden sie werden Bilder
davon gesehen haben sehen sie mir ein
bisschen hochsicherheit das ist schon
fertig gebaut wissen Sie ja ich weiß
doch
es ist Vorbereitung dort dafür auch
gebaut worden und genau solche
asylinderzentren müssen dann an der
Grenze entstehen Sie mir bitte nach dass
ich dieses Argument das ist rechtlich
nicht möglich nicht mehr kaufe denn es
ist rechtlich eigentlich kaufen also
Dublin Abkommen gilt eigentlich auch das
heißt jeder und jede die oder der
ankommt muss in dem Land den den Antrag
stellen und der muss dort geprüft werden
gilt auch nicht mehr also ich habe ein
anderes Beispiel für Sie auf jeden Fall
aber ganz ehrlich also
internationales Recht aber mal sehr
recht zum Beispiel und und
internationales Völkerrecht den
verflüchtlings Konventionen die wir also
das sind Dinge die wir glaube ich nicht
so über Bord werfen sollten auch aber
auch nicht können und unser Asylrecht
ist für mich auch
unumstößlich und deswegen müssen wir
natürlich nach Wegen suchen und das hat
die bundesinnenministerin auf
europäischer Ebene auch mit Erfolg getan
das ist jetzt lange Jahre nicht gelungen
dort mehr halten zu finden
das im nationalen raten Mehrheit
gefunden
die Leute gleichmäßig Aufforderung
hatten wir vorher schon in der Trilog
ähm ist jetzt dran auch diese Sache
umzusetzen aber im Nationalrat gab es ja
bisher keine
gab es ja bisher keine Mehrheit dafür
die hat aber Deutschland jetzt auch mit
der guten Kompromisslösung eben
herbeigeführt
Joachim Gauck weil sie gerade Dänemark
sagen ja zitiere denn Dänen ist es
gelungen eine nationalpopulistische
Partei und die gab's wir haben die
richtig getrieben unter drei Prozent zu
bringen mit genau dieser Politik und
dann kommt der Satz der harmlos klingt
aber der eigentlich was böses meint das
heißt wir müssen Spielräume entdecken
die uns zunächst unsympathisch sind weil
sie ihn human klingen und er sagt auch
an anderer Stelle und das fand ich sehr
interessant wir können natürlich immer
weiter versuchen an einem System
herumzuschrauben das ohnehin kaputt ist
und wir werden einen kaputtes System
nicht mehr in Gang kriegen hat er recht
nein ich bin nicht der Auffassung dass
Herr Gauck an der Stelle recht hat aber
auch wenn ich ihn an vielen anderen
Stellen durchaus schätze aber da geht er
Fehler ich bin der festen Überzeugung
dass wir in der Lage sind jetzt wo der
Schritt gemacht ist dass die Europäische
Union bereit ist ein solidarisches
System und funktionierendes System auch
umzusetzen dass wir es dann auch können
vor allem aber kommt es ja darauf an
dass wir die vielen Boote von denen sie
sprechen ihres gar nicht auf dem Weg
schicken weil Menschen andere
Möglichkeiten haben
eine wirtschaftliche Perspektive bei uns
zu suchen und gleichzeitig müssen wir
auch hinschauen es gibt derzeit über
über 100 Millionen Menschen auf der
Flucht auf der ganzen Welt die kommen ja
bei weitem bei sehr sehr weitem nicht
bei uns an sondern in meistens in den
Nachbarländern ihrer konfliktreichen
Heimat weil das sind tatsächlich
Kriegsflüchtlinge und und
asylflüchtlinge die eben in den
Nachbarländer den Armen Nachbarländern
meistens
binnen Migration ist ein riesiges Thema
aber wir sehen uns auch eigentlich es
überfordert irgendwann ein Land wenn wir
das so machen ich habe dieser Tage einen
Interview mit dem dänischen
Integrationsminister gelesen der sagte
wir brauchen harte regeln wenn wir
weiterhin ein humanes also System haben
wollen
ja und zu der Auffassung sind wir auch
gelandet und deswegen wollen wir und
haben wir auch die notwendigen
Voraussetzungen geschaffen die
Asylverfahren wesentlich beschleunigen
um sehr viel schneller sehr klar
festzustellen wer bleiben kann und wer
nicht und dann eben diejenigen finden
wir alle zurück soweit
wie hoch ist die Anerkennungsquote bei
Asylanträgen
die ist machen Ländern unterschiedliches
wissen sie auch ungefähr von allen die
kommen habe ich die Zahl habe ich nicht
parat 1% 2 nein das sind wesentlich mehr
Prozent das wissen sie auch also in
Afghanistan Syrien die Ländern
das sind insgesamt Wesen in Deutschland
in Deutschland die Haupt alle die
ankommen wie viele von denen kriegen ein
Titel einer südtitel von einer Million
wie viele
ich kann es nur nach Ländern sagen und
die Haupt zustrimmende sind ja immer
noch Afghanistan in Syrien neben der
Ukraine wo wir 100% Anerkennung haben
weil es ja gar nicht nach einem
Asylrecht geht sondern nach der
sogenannten Massenstrom
massenzustrom Richtlinie genau
Afghanistan in Syrien hat natürlich eine
sehr hohe Anerkennungsquote weil eben
dort ähm Bürgerkrieg und Verfolgung
herrscht und deswegen ähm
ist die Gesamtzahl natürlich auch höher
als das was sie unterstellen es gibt
aber auch Länder die eben eine sehr
geringe bleibe Wahrscheinlichkeit haben
die wir ja jetzt beispielsweise Georgien
und Moldawien auch zu sicheren
Herkunftsstaaten erklären wollen weil
dann die Asylverfahren auch schneller
ablaufen können als normalerweise
die Quote ist glaube ich ungefähr so bei
der Hälfte kann das sein was könnte in
die Richtung gehen das heißt wir
schicken die Hälfte der Leute einfach
dann zurück wir bringen die zurück in
ihre Länder 100.000 Leute wir schaffen
das wir haben vorher vom also eine
Million habe ich jetzt nicht
Ukrainerin Ukraine haben
aber keine Millionen geflüchteten die
auf die auf einen Abschluss ihres
Verfahrens warten glaube ich aber
sei es darum wir haben ja auch von der
von dem Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht
gesprochen das heißt vor allem
diejenigen die schon sehr lange da sind
sehr lange jetzt warten nicht mehr als
eine Duldung erreichen die gehören die
können wir auch nicht abschließen können
wir nicht abschieben die finden aber
dann mittlerweile Arbeit und wir haben
bisher nicht die Möglichkeit gehabt dort
einen Spurwechsel zu machen eben in die
normale Zuwanderung das haben wir jetzt
möglich gemacht
kurz wenn man sagt das ist zu viel und
es überfordert der Bundespräsident
Belastungsgrenze erreicht sie haben es
vorhin auch so ähnlich gesagt dann
spreche hier mit Landräten ich weiß was
da los ist logische Konsequenz dass
diese Rückführungen stattfinden müssen
also da muss man sich dann schon so
ehrlich machen dass das natürlich diese
Konsequenzen hat das kann man nicht dann
auch schauen ja das ist dann aber auch
wieder ganz schrecklich das habe ich
nicht gesagt nur um die Frage der
Logistik gehen okay
es sind ja sehr viele unterschiedliche
künstländer und und da muss da muss eben
das ist ja genau das Problem mit jedem
einzelnen Land bei jedem einzelnen bei
jeder einzelnen Rückführung verhalten
werden nehmt ihr den genau das ist ja
genau das Problem deswegen brauchen wir
diese Abkommen so und deswegen stellt ja
Joachim Gauck die ganz große Frage und
sagt wir müssen auch Dinge denken die
wir bisher quasi nicht gedacht haben
schlicht und ergreifend würden Sie sagen
Dänemark weil er das zitiert ist ein
Vorbild diesbezüglich also so wie sie
dargestellt haben dass Dänemark Politik
gemacht hat um eine rechtsnationale
parteiklein zu machen ich mache keine
Politik wegen der AFD wir machen Politik
wegen der Menschen und das sind sowohl
natürlich die humanitären
Verpflichtungen die wir gegenüber
geflüchteten haben aber natürlich auch
wegen der Menschen die hier sind wegen
der Landräte wegen der vielen
Behördenmitarbeiter in den
Kommunalverwaltungen die wir
unterstützen müssen die Schulen die
Kitas die alles auch unter Überlastung
klagen das heißt wir müssen die
Verfahren wesentlich beschleunigen damit
wir die die Schutz brauchen dann auch
gut aufnehmen können wir sind in der
Lage die gut aufzunehmen dann natürlich
sind wir in der Lage diejenigen die
Asylgrund haben
die Kriegsflüchtlinge sind die also
erstens müssen wir sie aufnehmen
zweitens haben wir durchaus die
Möglichkeiten zu tun aber wir dürfen
nicht so lange brauchen um die
Entscheidung zu treffen und deswegen
erstens die Verfahren an den
Außengrenzen die sind noch nicht
vereinbart im Trilog aber im nationalen
Rat und vor allem auch bei uns eben die
Verfahrensbeschleunigung und die die
Verstärkung der Rückführung von Januar
bis Mai hat Dänemark 1.000 Menschen
ungefähr aufgenommen 1.000 Deutschland
im selben Zeitraum
125.000 plus Nummer 10.000 Folgeanträge
Familiennachzug und so weiter wenn man
das sozusagen auf Deutschland
hochrechnet das was die Dänen haben wenn
das ungefähr 15.000 Menschen das heißt
die Dänen haben ungefähr neun bis zehn
Prozent unserer also Bewerber
ich habe es vorher gesagt deutschland
übernimmt viel mehr Verantwortung als es
müsste 36 Prozent der der geflüchteten
die in diesem Jahr in der Europäischen
Union warum wollen
die Frage warum wollen die alle zu uns
die wollen nicht alle zu uns sondern die
werden auch zu uns geführt das wissen
wir das ist ja durchaus klar sie hatten
es vorher gesagt diese Bilder werden mit
nicht die die sie jetzt zeigen sondern
die aus Lampedusa werden nicht ohne
Absicht produziert den Menschen werden
nicht ordentlich registriert sondern
werden direkt durchgeschickt auf den Weg
Skandinavien warum nicht Dänemark warum
nicht mehr Schweden warum nicht mehr
also
ich war vor kurzem in Norwegen ich war
ein Finnland da gibt es schon auch ähm
relevante
aufnahmebereiter nee nee nee aber
insgesamt aber insgesamt sie sind doch
was da politisch passiert
in Dänemark ist es eine von einer
rechtsextremen Partei getrieben
Sozialdemokratie in Schweden haben die
Schweden Demokraten ich habe jetzt von
Norwegen übernommen in Norwegen ist das
Thema ähnlich in Finnland haben wir eine
Regierung von der wollen wir nicht dass
wir eine solche Regierung haben absolut
da kommen jede Woche neue hässliche
Dinge richtig machen noch gar keine
Politik weil sie nicht mal